[Musique]
donc Saint-Laurent il y a des canyons
sous-marins dans lesquels se déclenche
de puissantes avalanches de sédiments
bien que ce phénomène soit invisible
depuis la surface il pose un risque pour
les infrastructures et la vie marine les
scientifiques cherchent à mieux le
comprendre
[Musique]
des mots contenant
S
rien ne laisse croire que ses pieds
c'est la BIM
[Musique]
au large sur le Coriolis 2 l'émission
scientifique s'enchaînent
les chercheurs ont les yeux rivés sur
ces curieuses crevasses
d'extraordinaire canyon sous-marin
d'une longueur de 4 km d'une profondeur
de 300 mètres sous la surface de l'eau
donc c'est les grandes sessions un peu
comme on s'imagine le Grand Canyon aux
États-Unis on voit la même chose dans le
fond de l'eau certains plus petits
certains plus gros vraiment pendant une
grosse tempête on a le courant qui vient
comme ça ça déborde au fil des ans
Alexandre normando et Patrick Lajeunesse
on cartographie ses canyon de loin en
large dans leur moindre détail
grâce à ce robot sous-marin qui sont de
les reliefs au fond de l'eau
il enregistre ces données de
positionnement mais aussi va prendre des
mesures de profondeur et des différentes
caractéristiques du fond marin
larguer du Coriolis 2 le robot autonome
plonge au fond du Saint-Laurent
équipé d'un échoondeur il révèle ce qui
se passe dans le cru de ces canyons
des avalanches de sédiments
identiques à des avalanches de neige
mais sous l'eau
[Musique]
reproduite dans un bassin en laboratoire
on peut imaginer comment ces énormes
masses de sédiments qui roulent dans le
fond marin peuvent tout emporter sur
leur passage
même endommager des infrastructures
comme des câbles de télécommunication
déposées au fond de l'eau
et donc si ces infrastructures-là sont
brisées par ces arranges de sédiments-là
ou par sédimentaire là mais ça peut
affecter notre vie de tous les jours
[Musique]
si ce qui est arrivé au large de
Terre-Neuve en 1929 il y a eu un grand
tremblement de terre de magnitude 7.2
qui le tremblement de terre lui a généré
un énorme glissement de terrain c'était
des centaines de kilomètres cubes qui
ont dévalé les pentes ce sont
transformés en avalanche de sédiment
comme ça
la masse qui s'est déplacée d'un seul
coup est assez importante qu'elle a
généré une vague énorme elle s'était
battue sur la péninsule de burin dans le
sud de Terre-Neuve et la fait 28 mois
dans le fond de l'eau 12 câbles
télégraphiques se sont brisés les
communications se sont rompues au rythme
de la cool et des sédiments
parce que cet événement là aussi s'est
produit et que brisé des câbles
sous-marins en descendant dans le fond
de l'eau on a pu voir la vitesse à
laquelle ça se produisait donc ça c'est
vraiment scientifiquement ça a été un
événement très important aussi pour
comprendre comment ces Avranches de
sédiments se produisent
mais on est encore loin de tout
comprendre sur les avalanches
sous-marines
pointez mon et l'endroit idéal pour les
étudier les canyons sont assez petits
pour être cartographiés et assise carpés
pour que les avalanches se produisent
une vraie mine d'information
en superposant des images des canyones
prises au fil des ans on voit apparaître
le mouvement des sédiments la trace de
ces avalanches sous-marines on voit des
structures des formes des dépôts qui
sont produits par des courants de
surdité donc par des avalanches de
sédiments et on repasse un an plus tard
deux ans plus tard puis on regarde
comment il s'est dit mais ont pu migrer
et donc le fait que c'est d'une
sous-marine le bouge dans le temps ça
veut dire que des Avanches sous-marines
qui se produisaient de façon plus ou
moins régulière mais comment savoir à
quel rythme c'est sédiments se déplace
au fil du temps
mais on voit en fait quand on est en moi
1 2 3 4 gros événements tout au long de
la carotte c'est les spécialités de Jean
Carlos Monteros Serrano elle est
responsable de trois dernières missions
un lien avec le projet et je suis aussi
responsable d'étudier la dynamique
sédimentaire à court terme
dans des Cagnes à pointément avec son
équipe il récolte toutes sortes de
données comme des carottes de sédiments
mais aussi des échantillons qui
proviennent de la colonne d'eau entre
autres avec des trains acidesment
disposés en aval du canyon et en plaçant
la trappe à sédiment à la sortie des
canyon ça nous permet de capturer en
fait l'événement complet en fait de la
tête jusqu'à la sortie du canyon
une trappe à sédiments c'est une sorte
d'entonnoir suspendue dans la colonne
d'eau les particules en suspension vont
graduellement s'y déposer à la base des
bouteilles montées sur un carrousel
recueillent les particules la rotation
des bouteilles se fait au 2 semaines
après une année complète sous l'eau on
récupère les trap acidesment le contenu
de chaque bouteille donne le portrait de
ce qui se passe dans la colonne doux au
fil des semaines un bon indicateur du
mouvement des sédiments oui c'est les
feux de partir que la mer
les carrosses c'est la dynamique
alimentaire à long terme
[Musique]
en laboratoire l'analyse des carottes de
sédiments récoltées au large de pointes
des monts permet de discerner les
différentes couches sédimentaires en
fonction de la taille des particules ici
elle est en couche des sables avec des
éléments phases et enfin ça c'est un
gros événement de remobilisation
sédimentaire et tout au long en fait de
la langue carotte aussi on boit des
couches de sable
ici il y en a une ici il y en a un plus
grosses
ça ça témoigne en fait de la dynamique
active des canyon à points
déclencheur de ses avalanches
sous-marines
c'était lié à un tremblement de terre
mais après un démon ce serait plutôt lié
des vents violents ce qu'on a pu voir
c'est que ça se produit pendant les
tempêtes donc ça prend vraiment des
tempêtes assez importantes qui
augmentent la hauteur des vagues on
pense que ça prend aussi de marée basse
parce que plus madame Marie est basse
plus l'impact des vagues va affecter le
fond marin par rapport à une marée haute
quand ces vagues-là déferlent sur la
côte ça remet en suspension des
sédiments puis ça génère des courants
désalanges de sédiments comme ça dans ce
brassage profondé sédiments il peut y
avoir un autre enjeu remettre en
suspension des organismes
potentiellement toxiques qui dorment au
fond de l'eau
Audrey Limoges de l'Université du
Nouveau-Brunswick s'intéresse à la
question
avec son collègue André Rochon elle
scrute une espèce d'algue microscopique
en particulier je suis en train de
scanner les champignons l'alexandria
durant son cycle de vie cet algue va
produire un kyste de dormance une sorte
d'enveloppe protectrice puis l'algue va
se déposer dans les sédiments au fond de
l'eau
mais lors d'une avalanche l'algue
endormi peut être propulsée vers la
surface et se réveiller de nouveau et
fait les conditions redeviennent
protestes si la cellule axé a
suffisamment de oxygène il peut y avoir
ce qu'on appelle l'excustement donc la
cellule va sortir de son enveloppe et va
pouvoir continuer son cycle de vie va
pouvoir se diviser pour lui faire dans
la colonne d'eau
le danger dans la quantité si l'algue
prolifère massivement elle peut causer
des marées rouges et la toxine qu'elle
produit peut se propager dans toute la
chaîne alimentaire
on ingère une quantité assez grande de
la toxine qui peuvent avoir des effets
néfastes sur notre santé
bien que les avalanches sous-marines
soient un phénomène naturel et invisible
depuis la surface elle pose un risque
sur les écosystèmes et les
infrastructures d'où l'intérêt de mieux
comprendre leur dynamique donc il y a
beaucoup d'activités qui se fait dans
nos océans évidemment de la pêche
présentement on parle de développer des
éoliennes extra-cotières il y a des
plateformes de pétrolière donc si on
sait que ces arrangements se produisent
on peut designer ces infrastructures-là
en fonction de ces risques naturels
sous-marins là qui existent
justement pour savoir où ces avalanches
risquent de se produire la cartographie
des fonds marins doit se poursuivre
car au delà de points démons le
phénomène au pays survient tout aussi
bien sur les côtes atlantiques que
Pacifique